If you thought Muhammad Hijab was having
a bad year, you need to check on Ali
Dawa. Hijab's been exposed for lying
about his secret hotel wives,
blackmailing a shake, using a
photoshopped screenshot and an AI
generated fake confession to discredit
one of his victims, and so on. But guess
what? All of that is totally forgivable
in the DA community. As long as you're
attacking Christians, attacking Jews,
attacking the Bible, you can do anything
you want. No one will ever hold you
accountable. Ali Dawa, by contrast, is
in a lot more trouble right now because
if you thoroughly embarrass the ummah on
their favorite topics, the Trinity and
the Deity of Christ, and if you're so
arrogant that you destroy your own case
with your own visual aid, your fans just
aren't going to be as forgiving. I know
people like to post so and so's career
ended by such and such and it's usually
not true, but this is a rare instance
where someone simply isn't going to
recover from the
embarrassment. So, what just happened to
Ali Dawa? Well, to his credit, he agreed
to have a street debate with God Logic
in London, but he tried to avoid
actually debating by begging for
prayermat donations. This is a guided
prayer mat. But let me tell you about
our charity. So we're a charity. We have
guided prayer mat. So now brothers and
sisters, the reason I'm doing this is
because we're doing a bit of
fundraising. Can you do a shout out to
the Americans to donate? Someone just
donated £500. 15 $20. I want people to
donate. Okay guys, we're £162 away.
£100. Don't forget to donate. If they're
not praying like Jesus, then don't
donate. Eventually, they debated whether
Jesus is God. Now, one of the most
common objections we get from our Muslim
friends is, "If Jesus is God, how could
he die? If Jesus is God, how could he be
born? If Jesus is God, how could he eat
food?" Notice these sound like different
objections, but they're really all the
same objection. God isn't the kind of
being who is born or who needs food or
who dies. So, how can Jesus be God if he
has properties or characteristics that
God doesn't have? This is an objection
to the incarnation. God taking on human
nature and entering creation as Jesus of
Nazareth. Alidawa raises the same
objection, but he tries to make it sound
more philosophical by using
philosophical terms that he doesn't
understand. He begins by saying that
there are three types of existence.
The first thing I want to say is this.
There are three types of existence.
Three types of existence. There's three
types of existence.
There is impossible existence.
Impossible existence. Yes. Impossible
existence. Is impossible existence a
type of existence. Watch God logic
instantly spot a problem with Ali Dawa's
favorite argument. Define like I'm going
to give you the definition. Yeah. Give
me an example of an impossible
existence. Okay. No, there are three
types of existence. Okay. Impossible
existence is like having a triangle
square. So, does it exist? No. So, it
doesn't exist. It's an impossible
existence. So, it doesn't exist. No, it
won't exist. You can't have a triangle
square. So, then there's only two types
of existences right now. No, we're going
to come to that. We're doing it bit by
bit. Oh, yeah. We just eliminated one of
them. Yeah. Yeah. So, impossible
existence is something like a triangle
square. A triangle square can't exist
because it would be a contradiction.
But that's not a type of existence. It's
a type of
non-existence. Saying there are three
types of existence and one of them is
impossible existence is like saying
there are three types of Muslims. Good
Muslims, bad Muslims and
non-Muslims.
Non-Muslims would not be a type of
Muslims just like impossible existence
would not be a type of existence. Ali
Dawa goes on to argue that the Christian
view of Jesus as fully God and fully man
is like a triangle square. It's a
contradiction. Why? Because Jesus divine
nature is independent. Doesn't depend on
anything else for its existence. While
his human nature is dependent. It
depends on something else for its
existence. According to Ali Dawa,
something can't be both dependent and
independent because that would be a
contradiction.
But God logic shows why it's definitely
not a contradiction
because Jesus has a divine nature. He
has a a nature that is independent.
Okay. You can't be dependent and
independent at the same time. Yeah.
Well, I I agree that you can't be
dependent and independent at the same
time in the same sense. I'm not saying
that Jesus is independent in regards to
his divine nature, dependent in regards
to his human nature. The law of
contradiction is that a statement can't
be both true and false at the same time
in the same sense. The statement David
Wood is in Great Britain can be true at
one time and false at a different time.
That's not a contradiction. If I say the
sun rises in the east, that's true in
one sense. It's true from our
perspective, but in a different sense,
it's false because the sun isn't
actually rising. The earth is rotating.
So the statement the sun rises in the
east is true in one sense but false in
another sense not a
contradiction. Likewise if I say the sun
sets in a muddy pool that's true in one
sense it's true according to the Quran
surah
1886 but in a different sense it's false
because here on planet reality the sun
doesn't set in a muddy pool. So the
statement the sun sets in a muddy pool
is true according to the Quran but false
according to reality not a
contradiction. Since Ali Dawa doesn't
understand what a contradiction is. He
keeps insisting that Jesus in Christian
theology is like a triangle square. So
God logic points out something else. A
triangle square cannot be the same
thing. Right. Now let me ask you this.
Can a triangle and a square be put next
to each other? Yeah. Okay. Is that a
contradiction? No. Okay. So I'm not
saying that the divine nature and the
human nature are intertwined and mixed
in are the same exact thing. I'm saying
that they're next to each other. They're
united in the person of Jesus. So
Christians aren't saying that Jesus
human nature is both dependent and
independent. We're not saying that Jesus
divine nature is both dependent and
independent. We're saying that Jesus
human nature is dependent and that his
divine nature is independent and that
the two natures are united. You can say
you don't believe that, but like it or
not, it's not a contradiction.
So, I'm not saying that Jesus is
independent and dependent in the same
exact way, in the same sense. That would
be a contradiction. I'm saying that he
has a nature that is independent and a
nature that is dependent. Two different
natures united in the person. That's
called the hypoatic union. This is
Christian theology. God logic shows in
multiple ways even a child could
understand that there's no
contradiction.
But he's not talking to a child. He's
talking to Ali Dawa who again doesn't
even understand what a contradiction is.
And Ali Dawa just keeps claiming that
there's a contradiction. The body, the
flesh is dependent, but the godly nature
is independent. My friend, we call that
an oxymoron. We call that a
contradiction. We call that black and
white because they are two total
opposites. That was part one of their
debate and it seemed like it was over.
But Ali Dawa found out that when God
Logic showed up on his channel, his
views shot up and more viewers meant
more prayer mat donations. So he showed
up to Speaker Corner for round two. And
he brought a gift, a gift that God logic
would soon use to end Ali Dawa's career.
Now guys, first time I am
buying my Christian friend, a present.
I even wrapped it up
myself in Peppa Pig. What did Ali Dawa
bring for God Logic? And how did it end
Ali Dawa's career? We'll find out after
a brief word about this video's
sponsor. Suppose Alidawa brings you the
perfect gift. And suppose this perfect
gift literally cost him his entire
career. You'd be a heartless monster if
you didn't get him something amazing in
return. But what can you possibly get
for the man who's lost
everything? Get that man an Artza box.
Artza is a company in Israel that comes
up with a new theme every few months.
They gather products around that theme
from small Jewish and Christian
businesses and charities and places like
Jerusalem and Nazareth and Bethlehem.
And then they ship everything in a box.
If you sign someone up with Artza, he'll
get spices, snacks, crafts, decorations,
soaps, jewelry, dishes, all kinds of
things straight from the land of the
Bible and produced by local artisans who
share their products with the world
through arts. It'll help Ali Dawa forget
about his embarrassment and help him
learn more about the book he can't stop
attacking. And we're proud of that. Of
course, even if you don't want to order
an Artza box for Ali Dawa, you can
always order one for yourself. Trust me,
you won't regret it. So whether you're
trying to cheer up Ali Dawa or you just
want some handpicked treasures from the
land where Jesus walked, sign up to
start receiving arts and boxes. The link
is in the description. Be sure to use
the promo code dizzle to get a discount
and to let them know who sent you.
Now back to Ali Dawa who showed up to
speaker's corner for a battle of wits
even though he was completely
unarmed. But he did come bearing gifts
including the gift of total victory for
god logic. Now since I
realized no logic doesn't know his
shapes the gifts were some shapes and a
little shape sorder.
Okay. Okay. When you talk about
triangles and squares, you hand you
something in front of you. Sometimes it
doesn't make sense. What shape is this?
Ali Dawa uses the shapes to make the
same silly argument.
This is the human nature person one.
This is the human nature and the divine
nature. You cannot when you bring them
together, it's a contradiction. You
cannot have a triangle square. Meaning
when you bring them together, you have
how many shapes? Two. But God logic uses
the shape sorder to show that two shapes
existing together is not a
contradiction.
So when you have when you have this,
watch this. This ladies and gentlemen,
this is a triangle, right?
This come this lad. Hold on. Let me hold
it. Okay. Hold it. Okay. But it's going
to fall out. Oh, okay. Oh yeah. So this
ladies and gentlemen is a square. Okay.
Okay. Really? Smart man. Okay. A square.
Are the squares next to each other?
Yeah. Is this a contradiction?
Well, is
it? No. A triangle square, something
that's a triangle and a square at the
same time in the same sense would be a
contradiction. A triangle and a square
together is not a contradiction. Just as
a human nature and a divine nature
together is not a contradiction. Again,
you can say you don't believe it's true,
but it's not a
contradiction. But it gets worse for Ali
Dawa because God logic uses the shapes
to further explain Christian theology.
So it's pretty clear Alidawa knows that
I am not saying that there are two
persons. We are saying that there are
two what? Natures. Very good. Oh, just
one second. So natures and persons are
two different categories. Do we agree?
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Good. So if I say that
there's two natures, I'm not saying
there's two persons. I know. If I say
there's two natures within one person,
I'm there's two different categories.
Yeah. Good. All right. So you said that
you're talking about one nature being
the same as the other. The opposite
nature being the same as the other
nature, right? Yes. Them being together.
Okay. Are these together? Not like that.
I didn't ask that. Are these together?
No. Not like that. I'm not talking about
that. When I put When I bring a triangle
and I bring a square and I bring it
together. How many shapes? Is this This
is two shapes. Good. Is this a Wait, I I
answered all your questions. Remember my
turn. Yes. I bring them together. Are
they Are they together? Is this a
contradiction? They are two. Alidawa
still doesn't get it. So he argues that
the triangle doesn't fit into the square
because it has a different nature. No,
no, no.
The triangle. Look, look, look. It still
doesn't fit. It still doesn't fit. It
still doesn't fit. So now what? Now,
hold on a second, guys. Why is this
triangle not fitting in the square?
There's another square.
Because nature exactly. And that was all
God logic needed for the death blow to
Ali Dawa's career. Watch this. It's
going to be super funny. Alidawa, what
shape is this? I hope it's funny you
laugh cuz Yeah, it is. What shape is
this? Triangle. That is a square. This
is a square. Okay. What shape is in the
square? Triangle. Wait.
[Applause]
You just told me that a triangle cannot
be in a square, but you just said that
this is a square that has a triangle in
it. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
[Music]
I'm a little confused.
So, wait. I just want to know. I just
want to know. Since this is a
square and this inside the square is a
triangle, is this a contradiction?
Welcome to Dawa, ladies and gentlemen.
Ali Dawa literally brought God logic a
shape sorter shaped like a square which
also had a triangle within it and then
he argued that a triangle can't be in a
square even though he purchased wrapped
and gifted a triangle in a square and he
still doesn't understand how insanely
stupid his argument is. He doesn't
understand what a contradiction is. He
doesn't understand the basic
philosophical terms he's using. Even
after his argument has been obliterated,
he keeps looking for people who are
ignorant and gullible enough to fall for
it. This is da and we're proud of that.
If you'd like to see another way to
explain the two natures of Christ to
your Muslim friends, be sure to watch my
video, If Jesus is God, how could he
die? I make the issue so simple even Ali
Dawa can understand it.
[Music]
You tried on that. You just backed on
me. You tried on that.
You just backed on me. This is a
powerful religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.